hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice attacking game you guys sent me
that I should cover as soon as I finish
with the World Cup and as the World Cup
now finished I'm getting to it so uh
thank you for that and whenever you have
a a fine attacking game or just a you
know um a wonderful game in general do
uh send it over I will definitely uh
enjoy sharing it with everyone else so
we have uh this is around eight of the
Abu Dhabi Festival in Abu Dhabi chess
festival and we have a bibisara sobayova
of Kazakhstan versus Panama of India uh
wonderful attacking game uh let's check
it out and see what's happening so here
we are upon to C4 by bibisara Knight to
F6 by uh pranav Knight to C3 and pawn to
C5 we have Knight to F3 and Knight to C6
so again at the Four Knights of the
English the symmetrical variation and
now the standard here is G3 or D4 baby
Sarah goes for D4 we have C characters
Knight captures and now Ponte E6 and
here again G3 is by far the most common
move but you go for Bishop to F4 and
okay it's not very very popular but it
has been played by some incredible
players like Magnus played its Fiddler
played at the Yanni bomb and she played
at uh Wesley so play that what his
girlfriend played it uh so many many
strong players played it and here we
have Pawn to A6 now this move is very
very rare and usually you will see it
when you have Knights on C3 and D4 much
like in this in the when you're playing
against the Sicilian A6 will be played
so here E4 now going for the for the for
the so-called maruti Pawn structure in
the bishop to B4 now uh of course
spinning the Knight the thread is Knight
captures on e4 and she defends it by
playing Knight captures in C6 B captures
and Bishop to D3 just nicely defending D
for Pawn so you don't have to worry
about Bishop captures and C3 and okay
you could Castle now and there is a game
where castles was played but here we
have Pawn to D6 and it is now as of move
9 that we have a completely new game
so okay she first starts with Ponte H3
and here pranav trades on C3 Bishop
characters and C3 so he gives up the
bishop pair uh to mess up her Pawn
structure now she has a double C pawn
and okay we have Pawn the five chases
away the bishop Bishop to E3 and now
Bishop to E6 and you can see that uh his
Pawn structure is much much better here
uh what she has in return is okay the
potential for uh for the open B file
which he does have as well but she does
have the bishop pair so if she can get
those Bishops to Optimal uh optimal
diagonals should be very good uh we have
castles and now Knight to D7 we have
Pawn to F4 it's time to strike against
the black king as the black king is
still in the center of the board he
captures an F4 and the bishop captures
and this is a before we continue the
game I would just like to point out the
uh the the importance of this F4 move
now just uh just the mere fact that the
black king is still in the center of the
board uh should you know give you sort
of your spidey sense should start
tingling we we have to play F4 because
if uh black captures we're gonna play
Bishop captures and we're gonna be
attacking the D6 Pawn black has to deal
with this and that's gonna prolong the
uh castling of the black king at least
for one more move it's always a good uh
thing to have in mind and of course if
you don't capture well then you always
have to worry about Point F5 which I
mean would trap the bishop so not not
the the greatest okay he captures an F4
Bishop captures and now Queen to C7 and
already we have the the mistake that
most likely cost pran of the game now
how you should play this if you already
played all the way to here is Queen the
B6 check now you could block with the
Rook you could move the king doesn't
really matter and now play Knight to E5
and this is the way to defend the pawn
and if a white persists let's say queen
to C2 if she will go after the pawn he
could play Rook to d8 and that's pretty
much it the pawn is defended next to
Castle and the good game everyone
however after Bishop characters on F4 he
uh played this Reckless Queen the C7
move and now she counters will Bishop
the C2 now the D6 Pawn is hanging and
how do you how do you deal with this uh
the problem is now okay you could still
go for the queen b695 idea but now it's
like admitting that Queen to C7 was a
terrible mistake and we've uh we've
spoken about this on the channel quite a
lot chess players never do this you're
never gonna admit you've made a mistake
and lose a Tempo uh but still if Queen
the B6 checking H2 and knights the E5
now now the D6 Pawn is hanging because
Bishop the C2 has already been played
and okay you could go for this Knight
captures and C4 attacks the White Queen
and once the queen moves you could
Castle but it's still gonna be very very
hard to play probably you have to play
F6 here first and then King F7 because
if your Castle E5 opens up and now uh
Checkmate is being threatened let's say
G6 through kt1 white has incredible
development uh something like Bishop G5
to F6 can be played maybe the queen
finds their way over to H6 and a chick
mating attack will be very very hard to
stop uh uh probably it will not be
possible objectively it's a it's a lost
game for black already this point so he
decided for Bishop captures on C4
instead this will win him the C4 pawn
and the C3 Pawn as you'll see Bishop
captures and D6 are grabbing the pawn
back but that's not really important the
important thing is that the black king
remains in the center of the board which
is the theme of this game Queen to A5
and now Rook death to as the Rook on F1
is still hanging so Rook F2 Queen
captures on C3 and now okay how do you
play this your Europa Pawn with black
but chances are you're not going to be
able to keep it Rook to C1 now
threatening some nasty Discovery so the
queen moves to E3 and now Bishop to a
for opening up a discovery on the
undefended bishop and C4 we have Bishop
back to E6 and now comes Rook captures
on C6 so she wins back the pawn uh black
is not up in material and the black king
is still stuck in the center of the
board so look at this the bishop slicing
over here Bishop slicing over here
remember at the beginning of the game uh
where uh pranava took on C3 we said okay
he has a better Pawn structure but she
has as the bishop pair now he has no
Pawn structure and her Bishop pair is
well definitely The Bishop's pair from
hell and here we have Rook to d8 if you
try something like F6 it does seem like
something you want to do F6 King F7 and
try to just bring the Rook into the game
it's too slow Bishop A3 and now okay
King F7 already Rook captures on E6 ends
of the game that's it if King captures
Queen to D5 is Checkmate there's no
defense so instead after Rook captures
on C6 he plays Rook to d8 gets another
uh Defender into a game also nicely
aligns it with the White Queen and here
we have Bishop to C5 making room for the
queen to enter the game and we have
Queen to G5 and now there are many ways
to end the game here there there's a
meeting nine there's the mating eight so
you know feel free to spot whichever one
you like uh pause the video and find a
win for bibisara while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh always uh
trying to find the quickest way to your
opponent's king and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
captures on E6 this is the quickest way
to do it and also you can play Queen to
D6 this is the second quickest way to do
it she went for Queen to D6 but just to
give you an example of why this is
fastest uh you're in check and your only
option is to give up the queen or to
capture The Rook so okay you're gonna
capture the rook and now you play Queen
to D6 with the threat of Queen captures
and then black will have no move so
you're gonna have to give up the queen
with Queen characters on C5 as of course
uh the queen is not defended the Knight
cannot move from D7 so we're gonna
capture and now after black play
something doesn't really matter you can
just start capturing Bishop captures
with checking captures Rook F7 check
King to d8 and queen to C7 check King 8
and now anything here will be Checkmate
so instead after Queen to G5 she played
Queen to D6 this is the second quickest
way to do it uh in and now we have
Bishop captures on H3 now she played
Queen to D6 because she wanted to end
the uh you know the the game with style
let's say if if uh silly movies played
then she can just sacrifice her Queen
and then if F captures Rook captures an
E6 with check and you have no moves you
have to block with the queen and Rook
captures will be Checkmate as the other
Rook controls the the entire f file so
instead she played he played Bishop
characters on H3 and now uh there's uh
well it's uh okay a sort of a useful
move but Rook the C7 just piling up on
that Knight on D7 and next uh well wait
until you see what happens next the
piranha played Pawn to H5 but she just
played The Rook the D2 brought a fourth
attacker to the Knight on D7 and he was
in this position on move 25 that pranav
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so 25 moves in
modern times in 2023 uh definitely is a
miniature and you've seen how easily you
know things just got completely out of
hand he uh
um play that Reckless Queen to C7 move
which was a terrible loss of a Tempo and
she just you know capitalized on it and
took advantage of it very nicely so here
you resign of course because there's no
move black can make there's really no
more black can make you cannot move the
the like you move the Rook Rook H6 you
attack the queen queen f8 is Checkmate
remember the Knight cannot move anywhere
uh other than that uh if you move the
queen from this diagonal then just Queen
to a queen to E7 is Checkmate so you
can't do that uh what else can we do
let's say we play a silly move uh you
play something like Pawn to H4 then you
get Pawn to E5 and now if you make
another silly move uh because you don't
have moves other than silly moves and
then you start capturing and these seven
Rook captures Rook captures Bishop
captures on D7 Bishop captures on D7 and
now just Queen captures will be
checkmates on regardless of what you do
you're just gonna start gobbling up on
D7 and very quickly deliver checkmate uh
so brilliant brilliant attacking game by
baby
uh if you have a if I'm mispronouncing
it I'm sorry I don't know how to
properly pronounce it uh do send me an
email you know with the correct
pronunciation and I will remember it for
future videos uh but yeah from move nine
where we had a completely new game uh
you know very quickly you know he he
gave up the bishop pair and already here
with this Reckless Queen to C7 move on
move 15 the game was basically over
there's no good way to counter Bishop
the C2 and it's uh probably uh something
you don't expect like you're probably
expecting a developing move like Rook to
B1 or something else like maybe Pawn to
C5 try and uh you know take advantage of
this and okay those moves could all be
counter but Bishop to C2 is such an such
an annoying little move and You Know It
uh you're you're trying to hang on but
it just uh you know completely
destroys you and why just takes control
over the entire board and there's really
nothing for you to do the Bishops become
Unstoppable uh that's you know pretty
much the story of this game so always be
careful in your own games not run into
something like that and even this uh
capturing on C3 maybe not all that maybe
not all that impressive uh and yeah it
was this was round eight like we said up
until this point bibisara did not lose a
single game and had she won in the final
round she lost in the final round but
had you won in the final round she would
be in the top 10 of the Abu Dhabi Chess
Masters and in good company just to give
you an example the tournament Was Won by
Vladimir fedose with seven out of nine
uh also with seven out of nine in second
place then we have a whole lot of
players with six and a half like uh like
Abdi Malik Abdi Salim who defeated her
in the final round then we have
chitaramba aravind then volodar music
those are the top 10. uh most of them
all on the six and a half points so it
was close but she lost in the final
round uh but yeah a very nice attacking
game hope you enjoyed it and thank you
for recommending it if you have any
other recommendations send me an email
or contact me on any social media or
just you know leave a comment using
hashtag suggestion and I will go over
your games uh so yeah that's the game I
really hope you guys enjoyed it another
English brilliancy if you will I would
like to thank gersney
chessfestival.org.gg Dennis frazato
samirangosh or Joshua chaudhuri and the
Robert Bloom for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on you
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and everything else that's happening in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day